♫ Why can't someone love
me like my best friend?
♫ Indulge me when I show my gratitude ♫
- What if your friends don't dance?
- Yeah, then they're no
friends of mine essentially.
- [Voiceover] Two Sumatran pour overs.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] Would you
guys like cream and sugar?
- No, we're good.
- Yeah, I would like...
I would like cream and sugar.
- We're fine.
You hear that?
That's that man in Central America
who picked these beans by hand.
Washed them, pulped them, roasted them,
and you're like ah no buddy, I'm good.
I'm just going to put, and ruin it.
- Do you guys need a minute?
- No.
- No, no, no, I would
just like cream and...
- For this, thank you.
As your friend I'm going
to show you the way.
Okay?
If you don't want to see it that's fine.
215 degrees really?
Four degrees under boil point max.
Well, well, well, well.
Hmm, really wow.
The big bubbles in the
pot when you're making
the water.
I'm going to do you a favor, okay?
- Okay, check please?
♫ Why can't someone love
me like my best friend?
♫ Indulge me when I show my gratitude ♫